i can snap my fingers and i can withdraw
a billion dollars of bitcoin from the
bank in five minutes and the thing
that's going to maintain its integrity
is the fact that you can shift
counterparties if you can move 10
billion dollars of an asset out of a
jurisdiction i can move it out of miami
i can move it out of a bank i can move
it out of a country i can move it out of
a system it's always going to have more
integrity than the alternative there are
a lot of people that don't think you
should have a software wallet on an
iphone you should have a hardware wallet
what if i don't want your family to have
it because i don't like somebody in your
family right what if i don't want your
small company you have a private company
do you own some bitcoin well you know
did you sell out now there's a company
that's got other corporate interests
that has some bitcoin a lot of people
don't want a public company to have it
why well public companies have
shareholders i don't want a country to
have it right i mean a lot of people
that are concerned that el salvador uses
bitcoin well it might get hijacked by
the politicians what if turkey actually
starts buying bitcoin do i like it do i
not like it but the point is it doesn't
matter what you think right
it's not
it's like you sitting and saying i'm
really angry that someone else is using
arithmetic other than me
right
it's spreading like wildfire it seems to
me
that the world's a better place if
people have monetary integrity than if
they don't have monetary integrity
i agree right
right um and in this particular case is
is this good
yeah of course it's good
right why is it good
it's good because
because um
what we want to do is fix everything
not destroy everything right
if you want to fix the bank
then
they replace their bonds with bitcoin
and the capital structure of the bank is
better
if you want do you want to fix every
publicly traded company in the world do
you want to fix the balance sheet of
apple and google and facebook and amazon
if i tell you that they have to do the
deal through an fdic insured bank
then you either can fix them
right there a lot of people don't want
to fix them they don't want they don't
want apple or google or facebook to fix
their balance sheet they don't want them
to fix their product but
but on the other hand i'm an optimist
what do i think i think eight billion
people should be using
uh using bitcoin as a digital asset now
there's two ways to do it the easy way
and the hard way the hard way is topple
every government in the universe destroy
every technology company and create my
own hardware wallet and my own
decentralized
well let's rip back to the network
destroy every big tech platform destroy
every big company and somehow let's
build something totally new that's the
hard way
seems pretty stressful to me what's the
easy way
the easy way is
all the big banks start issuing
stablecoin a token called the us dollar
right a u.s dollar stable coin and we go
from 130 billion dollars in stable coins
to a trillion dollars of stable coins to
10 trillion dollars of stable coins to a
hundred trillion dollars of
usd
and then eight billion people
have a have an iphone or an android
phone with it with a wallet and they do
10 20 50 transactions a day at the speed
of light
on the lightning network
on the lightning network and if they and
that's the best right a decentralized
non-custodial network moving the speed
of light for free next best is they move
these things around on the android or
the imessage or the what's up or the
facebook
layer 2 or layer 3 application right
that's second best and they do it
without toppling every government on
earth right like i
i can't
there's 130 currencies that are floating
right now
130. how many do we need well we we
certainly could get by the next step
with 12 right the c and y's not going
away and the usd is unless you wish to
topple
the government of china and the
government of the us and the governments
of the western world which i don't think
you want to do right you got bigger
problems if you did right like security
and safety and food
chaos and it would be a very very
painful situation for everyone yeah
right like so so if you if you look at
in
at an optimistic view let's just
actually make the world a better place
and a win-win for everybody so your
thought process is uh this asset which
has that monetary integrity that you're
talking about it's fully transparent
it's a in many cases you can look at it
as an automated central bank nobody
controls it it just sits there
programmatically executing what the code
says for it to do
that will serve as a global store of
value other people will then choose to
take their fiat currencies and upgrade
the technology doesn't necessarily
change their monetary policy but they
can then go ahead and digitize or
tokenize the dollar uh
the euro the end juan whatever currency
and then they would basically use the
bitcoin network payment rails to have
those uh assets fly around the world
however people chose but ultimately
people would go back to and settle in uh
bitcoin as that global store of value
partially but it's a it's a more
elaborate
idea which is
my idea is we incrementally upgrade
everything everywhere for everybody in
the most peaceful
least painful
least jarring way right so the inc
the incremental upgrade means
means uh
we deploy
to 8 billion people
to everybody on the planet we deploy
digital wallets and the wallet you have
a set of currencies and a set of assets
and in that wallet in argentina you've
got your peso and you've got your dollar
as currencies
if you want to hold something for a day
you hold a peso if you want to hold it
for a month you hold a dollar if you
want to hold it for a lifetime you hold
bitcoin right you've got digital assets
bitcoin is the strongest digital asset
um is it the only asset
no because you've got a company there
are buildings there's apple i still like
google i want my youtube i like netflix
right we need domino's pizza we need
bitcoin pizza someone's got to
manufacture the cameras that are staring
us right now got a microphone we can't
just have one asset we have multiple
assets
we have multiple currencies
will all currency survive no
the weak ones the ones that are truly
defective will go away 66 countries are
dollarized
there's 180 countries in the world how
many currencies do we really need
right we
right now it's china and the usd right
you might actually collapse down to two
but more likely you'll have the yen and
you'll have the euro and you'll have the
dollar
is there any currency in africa that you
really want to hold more than the dollar
if you had the freedom of choice
not really
what would you do though you need
you you need the local currency for
local payments right if there's a strong
local government you need the local
currency to pay your tax bills because
it's mandated by law you need the global
the global currency
and it's called the u.s the global
reserve digital currency the global
reserve currency you need that as a
medium of exchange if you want to buy
something in argentina from someone in
brazil or you want to buy something in
africa from someone in venezuela you're
probably going to swap dollars right why
because there's a hundred million
companies pomp
that have invested 30 years to create
accounting systems and point-of-sale
systems to process billions and billions
of transactions in those currencies
like my company does it i
i can actually swap my balance sheet to
bitcoin using three people and i can do
that in a matter of weeks
swapping all of my
vendor payments all of my payroll and
all of my receivables into bitcoin
that would be a billion times harder
okay
and it's not worth a billion times more
stress and effort it's not it's just not
worth it right it's
in an inflationary environment money
decomposes into a currency layer which
is losing value slow hopefully slowly
if your currency lost value one percent
a month but your asset gained value at
15 20 a year
that's stable
now
do we need to replace it
not this decade right i'm not going to
speculate 30 40 50 years out but i
rather kind of feel like
a a more nuanced idea
here's a nuanced idea
i want to build the 21st century economy
on a strong foundation of integrity and
trust and thermodynamic soundness and
energy pure energy
so
that means the balance sheet the
foundation of every institution
should be built on bitcoin
but
every institution has its own derivative
its own security from bitcoin so when
you create your company if you want to
take your company public
you should be able to issue stocks and
stock options backed by bitcoin i'm not
denying that
if turkey goes and they buys billions of
dollars of bitcoin they can keep the
currency they would be backing the
currency with
with a hard asset
how many institutions are there
in the world that need some control like
like maybe uh if i said to you can't
issue stock in a company is that good
for the economy not really if i said no
country can print its own currency
is that good
probably not really
right um because the politicians need
some power over the currency
right i mean unless you come up with a
way to generate all the food and all the
products that we need without companies
and without countries like when you
figure that out that's like a utopian
idea then maybe you can live with
bitcoin only and
and the like
but
in the meantime which is like let's just
focus on the next decade
because there's no point in solving this
problem after the year 2030 right yeah
right focus in the next decade the next
decade it works like this
all the big banks issue usd stable coins
what happens the us dollar replaces all
the weak currencies and it grows in
strength right the us dollar can become
the daily currency of six billion people
and it has been doing that for some time
you mentioned the dollarized country
right now
right now analog dollars in the 20th
century banking system is the reserve
currency of the world but it's an awful
inefficient system right yeah how do you
send a hundred dollars to someone on
saturday afternoon if they live in
africa if you live in south america
how send someone to a friend of yours in
paris
on a tuesday i dare you right so the
point right now is the us dollar is the
world's reserve currency but it's
running on on 20th century rails
so the u.s dollar should evolve to run
on crypto rails it should run on you
know we can debate right lightning rails
what's up rails
you know any other crypto right
interesting question but what we can't
debate
which is 100 certain is everybody wants
to be able to move the money at the
speed of light and program it on a
computer chip on a saturday afternoon
that's that
sometimes we get in this uh in this
confrontational state where people think
well it's bitcoin versus the fed or
bitcoin versus the dollar
it's not right we can all win
right it's a win-win here it's in the
best interest of the dollar to move at
the speed of light and be programmable
and there's a hundred million businesses
that want to do business in the dollar
and
i am the controlling shareholder of
micro strategy i found the company i
mean there aren't that many ceos that
have more power than me if i walked into
a room and i ordered
everybody in my finance team to convert
over all the accounting systems
and stop and sell everything and and
satoshi's right and pay everybody in
satoshi's you understand that uh if
everybody didn't quit on the spot
it would be a decade and a billion
dollars of work
and it wouldn't work and by the time i
finished the billion dollars of work the
company operation would go to zero right
it's literally a death sentence for a
big institution to attempt
to convert over its um its mediums of
exchange and its accounting systems for
for routine transactions